[Music]
this is really such a treat it's not
very often that you get to introduce a
national treasure and here he is he's a
bonafide a national treasure
so Michael Morpurgo the author of about
a hundred and thirty books I think he's
not entirely sure himself how many he's
written but many of which have been
adapted for stage and television as I'm
sure you will know including warhorse
the book that made him a household name
he started out as a teacher and with his
wife Claire he set up the charity farms
for city children which has given over
90,000 children in the last 40 years the
experience of spending time in the
countryside he also helped to set up the
post of Children's Laureate with his
friend Ted Hughes and he was a third
writer to hold the post in 2018 he was
knighted for his services to literature
and charity said he has an official of
knight-errant and we are here today to
talk about his wonderful new novel boy
giant so Michael thank you so much for
coming to join us thank you
let's start with the the starting point
for this story because there's so much
to talk about around it what was the
beginning point for this book was it the
the historical work of literature that
it's based on all the contemporary
resonance that we're going to talk about
later on
well this doris swift story came first
obviously
I grew up with it like a lot of kids did
didn't never read the whole thing like
most kids don't you just read the bit
about Lilliput because it's the fun bit
about the little people and that's
that's what I learned when I was little
then I have a wonderful colleague or
Michael for Manu illustrates my books
often and at some point twenty-five
years ago said Michael we got to do
Gulliver's Travels Gulliver's Travels
you've got to do you've got to so I said
well no because it's been done and done
and it's an Lilliput in its little
people and they're fine and I tried to
put him off and it's I succeeded until
two years ago and two years ago you said
Michael we still haven't done Gulliver's
Travels and I said it's still about
little people
and and a giant who wears big shoes with
silver buckles and I know and then and
then and then I started making strange
connections all of us will remember
seeing images on our televisions of dead
children being carried along beaches
whether it's in whether it's in Greece
or turkey or wherever and we know how
that Sears the soul and you don't forget
it but the trouble is you do forget it
because something else comes along
that's more important and blocks all
that off and it's there is nothing more
important and I thought well maybe maybe
Swift wrote that story originally
because he was having a go at the
society around him but you very much
disapproved of well I very much
disapprove of our society and I was
thinking to myself I don't think Swift
would mind if I took some of his story
and brought it into our time and I had
the instead of the Gulliver washed up on
the beach being a sailor from that time
in that history ah
an Afghan refugee washed up on a beach
and it's on a beach of Lilliput of today
which hundreds of years ago had been
visited by this Gulliver who would warm
the people of Lilliput that if you go
down the route that my civilization is
going down you will be embroiled in Wars
and corruption don't do it and they had
devolved on this island in my mind's eye
a way of living which is not shangri-la
it was just a way of living which the
the essential principle underlying is
that you look after each other that's
finally what it is so I thought of doing
this and then I went to a bookshop in
Paris which many of you have been will
have been to and my granddaughter works
there and my granddaughter gave me a
badge which I was very struck by it said
this if written I believe by George
Whitman who was the person who helped
found the shot many many years ago be
not inhospitable to strangers lest they
be angels in disguise
I thought okay that is they're going to
be the theme of my book so it's a
strange sort of book it's a risky sort
of book but I thought go for it
well it's an interesting mix this book
because it is in the way of Gulliver's
Travels there is a lot of satire in
there and it's very funny in places but
it is also kind of deeply heart-rending
as it would be when you're dealing with
the story of of child refugees um but to
go back to the satire tell us a bit
about the the egg Wars of Lilliput
because I can't help feeling you're
talking about this ridiculous absurd
conflict that has divided families and
divided people and divided an entire
population from each other over such
small absurd differences like I cannot
feeling there's some sort of parallel
that that that you're aiming for here
yes it's not terribly subtle is it
though the truth is that well I'm a war
baby I was born in 1943 I remember
nothing of the war but I do remember the
aftermath of the war I finally in a
strange sort of way decided after a
while that I had to prove myself in that
world I went into the army I did all
sorts of funny ways of arriving at where
I've arrived and what I discovered after
a while and which is what I think a lot
of people discovered is that wars are
fought over extraordinarily small things
which are made to grow into big things
now whether that be religion or the way
we govern ourselves or our history or
whatever so much of it complete sorted
out by sitting down and talking and in
the end of course it always is
unsatisfactorily but nonetheless it
sorted out so it seems to me to be part
of what this society in Lilliput has
done it's worked out that you don't
quarrel with your neighbors and they
have got as you'll read the story you
know they have got a neighbor who is
threatening and they don't go back and
threaten back what they tried to do is
to talk it through and talk it through
it doesn't necessarily work but they go
on doing it so in yes I wanted to make
that that point fairly starkly but it's
a silly world that goes to war it's also
a very tragic world
you talk about your own childhood during
the war and I know you've talked about
how disruptive the war was to your own
families do you think that's why it's
something that you want to return to in
stories for children in up to look at
the way that these kind of conflicts can
be so disruptive for children who
perhaps don't understand the wider
context I'd never never think I'm
writing for children at all
I write for me selfishly I mean I write
because I'm interested in the subject I
want to tell a story I'm a story maker
in a sense I don't care who reads the
book I hope people do lots of people but
I don't care that about their age at all
I don't think when I'm telling a story
this is for a 10 year old or an 11 year
old because the minute you do that you
patronize your audience your tart
talking down to them and we know just
from the last few days what children can
do what they are thinking about how
seriously did they take the world you
patronize them at your peril and I've
always known that I've known that as a
when I was a child and when I was a
father and I've been a teacher so I saw
no needs in all sorts of from all sorts
of points of view and I think it's
really important as a writer that you
don't do that you don't just think well
actually they just like funny stuff or
vulgar stuff yeah of course they like
that and that's fine and they've got
that but you must tell the stories you
want to tell and I tell the stories
about the world as I see it and I don't
pretend I look children in the eye and I
tell them how I think it is I may be
wrong but I'm just telling them that and
they get that they quite like I think
the honesty of someone who just sort of
says it they don't have to agree with it
I don't want them to agree with it but I
wanted to think about it but the most
important thing when you finish the book
is that you come away doubting not you
come away because you found some great
belief you come away thinking about it
dreaming about it so I've gone on and on
and on about stories in schools endless
they're not being taught to the test
that we don't just do it but for a
comprehension test or a punctuation test
the last primary school I taught it you
know what a wonderful head teacher used
to say to us you finished the school day
every day from tray o'clock to hop us
three you tell them where you read them
a story and you do not ask a single
question about it you just let them
go out of school with this story in
their head and that seems to me to be so
important not to deliver solutions to
children but to deliver questions so I
never never write for children I'm not
sure why I blurted all that out it's
because you suggested I was writing or
thinking about the children I think
which of course I do I'm and be silly
and say I don't think about them you
know what I do I write about them so the
hero in my story this story as in all of
them is a child that's important or
young people they're going to be a child
so for instance in War Horse if we must
mention that and it's not about a child
it's about a horse but it's also about a
young boy and it's about the young boys
who went off to that war on all sides
but it is about essentially young people
when you say that this one is a is a
risky book do you mean in the sense that
you're you're putting questions into
children's minds or that you are
countering certain narratives that
perhaps people might have heard
regarding refugees or the way that
refugees are regarded I think if you put
your head above the parapet about
anything to do with migrants and
refugees you're asking for people to
have a go at you and particularly if
that book is going to go into the
classroom and I understand that it is it
is deeply currently controversial but
all the more important to write about it
that's what I mean the thing is these
children these children see this stuff
you know they they see it as an
sometimes as much as we do
they have it on their tablets they have
it on their phones they see these images
they have seen that child being carried
along a beach this is not something that
reserved for adults they see it and they
have a response they have thoughts about
that and it seems to me if you are
writing stories that you know are going
to be read by children you have to
engage with what it is that they are
engaging with in the real world because
the complexity of growing up now is
unbelievably more difficult than when I
was little I mean if I can't many people
here are not that old I'm glad to say
but if I could I'd take you back to the
1947-1948 it wasn't a perfect life a
great life it was a much simpler life
your parents did not have to guard
against this and that all the time you
what did you do you either played out or
you played in
and maybe you listen to the radio they
prevented you from finding out about the
wicked world out there either down the
street or in foreign places that they
didn't bring that because they thought
you couldn't understand it and they're
probably right about certain things and
so you grew up much more slowly not
dying it was not a Dilek but you grew up
much much more slowly and sometimes you
didn't talk about things because they
supposed and I think they were a little
bit right not completely right but they
supposed that there are certain things
that are too traumatic to keep going on
about so I came from a family which had
been there was a divorce in the family
my mother met someone else during the
war and there was a divorce just after
while I was completely unaware of it
except that my name I knew as I was
growing up was not my name and that
perplexed me I did have another name but
it took me until about the age of 10 to
discover what that name was and I didn't
meet my father till I was in my 20s
mostly because things were hidden I
don't blame anyone for that that was
just how people were then the problem
here now I think with you children is
that nothing is hidden it's all out
there and they've got to deal with it
whether it's the stuff at home or the
stuff out there they have to deal with
it and so their books their stories
their plays their music their dance
everything has to reflect the complex
deer that we kind of tie it all up and
put a little pink ribbon about it and
and and and just say well it don't have
a happy ending it'll be all right
that's patronizing them yeah I suppose
that's what I was getting at when I was
thinking about when you write about
issues that you know subject matter that
is potentially distressing or difficult
yeah and and writing about that knowing
that your books are going to be read by
children do you have to sort of come at
it from a particular angle and think
this is the kind of sensitivity I have
to bring to this because I want children
to to understand these issues and be
aware of it without being overly kind of
distressed or or traumatized yes you do
but I think it has to be all the
subconscious a minute you do think about
it then you will do this patronize
anything I think that the lucky thing
for me is that I've was a child I
remember but I was also father young
father and I'm now grandfather and a
great grandfather
so I've dealt a lot with children in
terms of
how to talk to them yeah and then I was
this schoolteacher and I engaged them I
would tell them my my own stories and I
would take them as far as I thought they
could go without it being um in any way
traumatizing but I would tell it hard if
there was something I felt that was
important then I wouldn't hold back can
give you an example of this really I've
there's been a play of warhorse on for
some time now which I've been to far too
often but I've been to it and one of the
wondrous things about it apart of the
fact that it's an extraordinary
production is watching an audience come
out afterwards and how the play has
affected different generations in the
same family so you'll have
eight-year-olds coming without out with
their fathers and mothers with their
grandmothers and grandfathers and
they've all brought their lives to this
story it's the same story but they've
all brought their life experiences to it
and it sort of tells me that if you can
write a story that does have some kind
of universality then then maybe that's
wonderful in the National Theatre made
it better than the book it is broader
than the book the characters are more
interesting in many many ways but the
idea is the same I think in really on
the same sort of lines one of the
recurring themes in all of your work
really when it comes down to it it's
about empathy it's about wanting people
to understand what someone else's
experience might be like and what might
lead that person to do the things that
they do yeah even if that's a person who
is particularly unkind or not you know
it's always about trying to recognize
that I think what was that something
that was a driving force for you when
you started writing that idea of wanting
to communicate and wanting children or
wanting your readers in particular to
think about different people's
experiences outside of their own isn't
that what all literature is about
finally I mean if it's worth anything
it is this extraordinary way it enables
us to understand the lives of others and
the places of others it takes you places
where you've never been
if you are young you could live as an
old person if you're female you can live
as
you you find out so much more about the
world which you cannot do in your own
life to start with as you grow up you
can explore it more and more but you can
explore it in literature from a very
young age and in an extraordinary way
and I find that the whole business of
being able to think yourself into other
situations and know that there's a there
are other lives out there that for some
time within a book are absolutely as
important as your own and when you
discover you discover how other people
think what other people believe that
seems to me to be critical about our our
whole education if we if we have people
leaving school whether they live at 16
or 18 or whatever and they don't
understand more about other people's
than themselves outside their city
outside their country outside their
continent then we're heading for an even
bigger mess than we're in at the moment
the prime reason for having education as
far as I'm concerned is knowledge and
it's understanding both together they go
side by side well that's been wonderful
actually about coming at this festival I
was sitting in the tent early wrong and
when you go to some festivals all you do
is talk to other writers boring but when
you come here I've met already musicians
I've met scientists and it's this kind
of if you if you are reaching up with
the people that you meet either in real
life or in books that's the way you
discover and go on discovering and to
give children the idea that this is the
way you find out about the world about
you about your place in it and books can
really do that for life they can do that
and if part of the journey is one of my
books then that pleases me I can't tell
you how much it pleases me sometimes to
get a letter from a teacher who writes
and says I was reading I don't know the
butterfly line to their children and I
couldn't finish it I was in bits I was
in tears and this kid put up her hand
and said I'll finish it for you miss and
how wonderful it is for a child to see
that a grown up particularly grown they
respect and admire he's touched by a
book that moved by a book I mean I was
read to by my mum she was an actor very
beautiful as all mothers are and I had a
wonderful reading voice and she'd read
to me I don't know
Walter de la mer Kipling all sort of
poems that people Stevenson Stevenson
was my favorite and she'd read me these
poems but read him in a way which was
passionate
I knew she loved them and she was
passing on that love and when you have
letters you know a teacher's been doing
that or a parent's been doing that and
the children have responded then you
think well actually it's worthwhile it's
worthwhile writing I'll write another
book do you think it's becoming even
more cry mean obviously it's even more
critical now that we encourage children
to to think outside of their own
understanding in to try and empathize
with other lives and this is happening
at a time when the arts are being cut
back and back in schools and it's
getting harder and harder to bring
children those experiences of art and
literature
what would you advocate as a solution to
bringing that back into the class well
you never close another library that's
for sure ever that should be a rule of
any government come in not just they're
not closed them but to make them better
and open up new ones if you want
literature to be for everyone it's got
to be free at the point of delivery like
the Health Service it kind of be
something you just if you can afford it
you buy it at Waterston's it has to be
free it's for everyone it's our it's our
right it's our heritage and I'm feel
that very very strongly and unless it is
for everyone and this kind of education
is for everyone then but then we are
going down the tubes it's really
important that we cling to the culture
that we've got and we enhance it and
enhance it and I know everyone this room
this tent knows that if you see how
people are taken by wonderful music by a
great story and taken to other places
and what they are learning from it and
how it widens you and deepens your life
and enriches you for the rest of your
life this is not about and the problem
is that people see it as outcomes all
the time you know we'll close the
library well what does that matter you
can get it online when you can't you
know and I think that the people who are
doing that are just taking a short way
really to is to impoverish our children
in a way that just as important is not
giving them enough vitamins you know
it's really important um I mean the
success of your books has allowed you to
have a a public platform where you
you've not
away from voicing opinions that have
been good that are sometimes
controversial I wonder if that was a
role you ever sort of sought out or
thought that you would have as a kind of
public advocate for literature and and
for the importance of no I never did I
mean when I was a teacher who were
limited of course to your classroom and
doing what you could there but I
certainly realized after I've written a
story or to him one or two of them have
been widely read the first thing I
recognized was that there was an
internationalism about this that I
responded to when the books got
translated and I find myself talking
about books in in in Israel in in in
France in in in Palestine in Australia
and you realize that literature was this
wonderful wonderful way of connecting
with people I thought well that's worth
not just writing books for but talking
about and I think bit by bit by bit as I
got older I think will you actually have
a responsibility to speak out and say
what you think and since I again this
might ring true with some people in this
room you get do get to an age where you
don't care what people think anyway you
know I really don't care I think what I
think I hope it's going to not hurt
people's feelings to say what I think
but the most important thing is to say
it to speak it out not to be silent when
you know something is not right so tell
us a little bit about when you set up
the Children's Laureate
role was that a part of an extension of
that idea of the idea that writers
should have a public platform and should
children's writers should be more
visible no it was because I had too much
to drink one night I had a great
neighbor and Ted Hughes II was down the
road and we used to have quite a lot of
good meals together and good wine
together and one night I was bemoaning
after two or three glasses a really nice
chateauneuf-du-pape I said to him
something like you're the something poet
laureate I think we should have a
Children's Laureate because people need
to speak more about the importance of
literature for children because it is
important and valuable and he said well
actually you're right that I am as
pleased or not pleased with the books
that I've written for young people as
the ones I've written for adults that
they're all important yes good idea
Michael um let's make a list of the
people we need to talk to he was very
like that but
so we another glass of wine and we wrote
down names of important people to go and
see to make it work anyway a year later
sadly sadly he was dead but here later
we had our first Children's Laureate it
was Quentin Blake the reason for the
whole thing really was this that there
has been and there still is this feeling
that if it's for children it's not that
important it's been there in our society
for a very long time people demean them
put them to one side say well you know
they don't know much surely young
they'll grow up and it's alright if it's
good enough for children the wonderful
thing for instance about what the
National Theatre has been doing and the
Royal Shakespeare Company now have been
doing in terms of their productions for
young people and for families is that
they brought the best of British theatre
for children when you bring the best
whether it's the best writers the best
illustrators and that's what we felt at
the time that if you make great books
good books and they are there for
children and it has prestige in the
society you do have these books reviewed
and spoken about and have your champions
column laureates called what you like
but have champions who can get up there
and speak up for children and their
rights to have good book to read it was
very much about that we were quite it
wasn't just the why and we were quite
passionate about it Ted use all the time
was trying to enable young people to
write he wrote a wonderful book some
people know called poetry in the making
which was his invitation to young people
to pick up a pen and write it's the best
book I know do that and it interested
him that you had to reach out to
children and find what it was that they
had as a talent in there somewhere and
he always said you we are all we all
have a story to tell
we all have the poet inside us most of
us never get to the point where we have
the confidence to write it down and this
was his invitation come on you can do
this you can do this and I spent most of
my life trying to say the same thing to
children I wonder if you can tell us
just a little bit about your farms for
children project and then I know you've
got farm subsidy children it's my wife's
idea it's wonderful how these things
start and they start as a child when she
was seven she had a rather wonderful
father was a publisher called Allen Lane
who started Penguin Books and he was the
eldest daughter
and she was a pain and I think during
the holidays the family decided let's
let Claire go somewhere where she's no
trouble and they had a friend who kept a
pub in Devon and they sent her down for
her holidays in Devon and she was 7 8
years old and she was in the middle of
this countryside staying in a pub it's
very bizarre and Auntie Peggy she was
called um didn't like her having around
under her feet too much so sent her out
every morning put on your wellies Claire
go out and she would spend her day going
out walking the countryside at a time
when there weren't many cars and people
weren't saying don't talk to strangers
it wasn't that world it was a different
world and she just went out there and
explored it in her wellies and she found
out about nature she was very close to
the ground so she found her first slow
worm and her first nisard I'm afraid she
kept them rather too long some of them
but we won't go there but she just
became fascinated by everything that
lived and crawled and flew and then she
woke up a lane and she meet farmers and
they say come and groom the horses or
come and feed the calves but you became
really in love I suppose with that
particular countryside teddy was called
it down the deep plains he called them
deep legs huge great high can't see
we're going at all anyway she'd loved it
so luckily for her she married me later
on she was a teacher by this time I was
a teacher by this time when we both came
to the conclusion it you can only teach
children so much inside the school the
children we were concerned about needed
to broaden their horizons needed to have
the same wonderfully rich experience she
had had and she said let's start this
this charity of a bullet farm subsidy
children her daddy's an inane de just
died and left her some money so bought a
large house and a farm with a partner
farming pond and we started invited the
first children down from Birmingham and
now we've had a close on 100,000
children coming for the last 47 years
from Birmingham Bristol Manchester all
over there's kids down there now I saw
them before I left yesterday and they
come and they live come for a week with
their teachers 35 40 of them live on the
farm work on the farm and they go back
having had the experience of a lifetime
they haven't loved it all there they
have to walk when it's cold when it's
rain they have to collect in hay when
it's hot they do all that's possible
within the bands of Safety's so it's a
way of it
sending their horizons really that's
what it is and we've loved it it's given
an enormous amount of in inspiration to
me a lot of joy to her so it's very
selfish and we've loved doing it is that
experience and what that's given you how
do you think that that has informed the
way you write about animals so often and
the relationship between children and
animals and really lucky and warmer
perhaps a unique experience of living
and working with kids for certainly
thirty years of my life out on a farm
day-in day-out I'm milk cows them I move
sheep with them we do all these
extraordinary things together and I've
watched these children observed them how
they get on with animals now the animals
get on with them the book warhorse
really came from one child from
Birmingham who came down called Billy
teachers warned me there's a school that
came in came and they trusted me and I
trusted them they said Michael please
don't ask Billy direct questions he
hates direct questions because it means
he's got to speak and he doesn't speak
he hasn't spoken for two years at this
school and he will run away from Devon
back to Birmingham he runs out away all
the time
muscle you mustn't do it so I said fine
I'll leave him be and I watched this
Billy all week and he did did the work
he was wonderful with the animals he was
very connected to the animals he clearly
had a great feeling no fear at all but
he would not talk to anyone none of his
friends teachers and I didn't even tried
to answer the question I did what I was
told
towards the end of the week I used to go
up and read them story and evening on
the last evening they were there and I
walked into the yard on a dark November
night Billy was there in there on the
outside step in the yard by the stables
he was in his pajamas it was pouring of
rain and he had his slippers on and I
was about to shout at him to go back
indoors when he suddenly started talking
to this horse he be she was cold and he
had his hand up and he his hand on her
nose was talking very quietly and I
stood where he couldn't see me and the
shadows around the corner but I listened
and he told that horse what he'd done on
the farm that day so I ran round fetch
the teachers brought them back I said
look look look look this is he talks he
talks
so somehow this animal this wonderful
[ __ ] had unlocked whatever it was was
holding his tongue freezing his tongue
and he was speaking and he just talked
and talked and talked and the teachers
were amazed I was amazed and what it
convinced me was that there is this
connection between children and animals
which is elemental which is not
sentimental and it enabled me to go sit
down afterwards and go and write a story
about a horse that I suppose can write a
book and understands other people in
different languages and their touch and
their comfort and their love and their
trust because I'd seen all that with
this boy so it massively influenced my
life as a writer because I'd had these
insights which went on day after day
after day and then insights into myself
as well and just before we go to
audience questions I know you want to
tell us about another charity that
you're involved with yeah I just thought
it was important to talk about it I
don't know if any of you has seen this
this flag it's designed by the Chinese
artist Ai Weiwei and a group of Rae
I think a theatre people mostly all over
the world this country to have got
together
it's called fly the flag and it's
because all of us feel at the moment
that human rights are under threat
though either being ignored or they're
actually under threat and we want to fly
the flag for human rights and a way way
when to took a footprint of a refugee in
the sand and made this flag and I just
wanted you to see it but it's very
important to me because it seems to me
that it's the great freedom that we've
seen to be losing at the moment a sense
of these rights that we got the children
have got them we've got them and we take
them for granted at our peril I mean I
what I want is in 10 20 years time that
this flag is out there like the peace
flag and the people understand it's for
our rights and people suffered and died
over hundreds of years for this and we
still haven't achieved what we should
have achieved anyway that's what I
thought I'd tell you I'm sorry
it's something I'm passionate about at
the moment and it's a wonderful piece of
art I didn't do that myself I promise
that's AI weiwei hmm and it's really
what this book is also happens to come
at the same time as this book I'm Sophie
thank you so much Michael for all your
wonderful words this afternoon and can I
thank my wonderful interview as well
could you give a huge hand please thank
you for coming for Maude abates talks
and interviews subscribe today to the
Institute of Arts and ideas at IAI TV
you